[Music]
welcome to the stanford mba session on
your journey in preparing for a career
off the beaten path my name is lisa
jananjali and i'm a director of mba
admissions at the stanford graduate
school of business
or the gsb as we affectionately referred
to it i'm also an alumni of the program
as well and i'm delighted to be joined
by some of my fellow alumni today who
will share a bit more about their
experiences
but here's what to expect from today's
session
we'll talk a little bit about where your
journey might take you you'll have an
opportunity to meet our panelists
i'll start us off with a little bit of
questions and answers to get us going
and then we really want to spend some
time answering your questions as well so
at any point again feel free to submit
your questions in that q a box if you
see a question that someone else has
asked that you also particularly like
you can click on that little thumbs up
symbol which will help vote that up to
the top and we'll have about 55 minutes
together today and hopefully this is
just a wonderful opportunity for you to
engage with our community and to learn a
little bit more about the stanford gsb
experience and how it might enrich your
professional opportunities going forward
so let's talk a little bit about where
your journey will take you
so here you see some recent stats from
our class of 2020.
91 of our students had job offers three
months after graduation
445 different organizations hired our
mba students for either summer or
full-time opportunities
and 71 percent of our students were
making a career pivot whether it was an
industry function and or location or
some combination
of those three
now oftentimes when we think of mbas we
think of some of those typical post mba
industries so finance technology
consulting but i think one of the
wonderful things about this session in
particular is that it really highlights
how
flexible an mba education is and how can
really take you in a number of different
directions
you'll note in the class of 2020 19 of
our students
immediately went into socially
responsible roles 18 started new
ventures uh and for the sixth
consecutive year we have record high
compensation within the nba market so
we're also very very proud of that
but let's take a moment now to meet some
of our alumni and some folks whose um
paths have led them to sort of
job opportunities or professional
opportunities that are sort of off the
beaten path for our
mba students
we'll have each of our panelists briefly
introduce themselves
jackie would you like to get us started
yeah happy too
um the gsp was an amazing experience and
prior to grad school i worked in
philanthropy and social entrepreneurship
i ran a couple different non-profits and
then during graduate school i got really
passionate about women's sexual health
market and how to use business to create
more equity related to sexual health so
for the first year or so business school
i explored investing i worked in venture
capital
and interned and impact investing
in the sexual health market um and was
interested in starting a fund at first
and then i became really passionate
about discrimination and advertising
where a lot of entrepreneurs couldn't
advertise women's health products
because they were being misclassified as
adult products despite
mass odds being allowed for erectile
dysfunction
so i decided to create a non-profit that
does advocacy and policy work to change
tech policies um but i'll briefly also
mention that what's been amazing about
the gsb is that it also creates
opportunities to to try completely
different areas with a lot of amazing
support so since grad school i've also
been delving into investigative
journalism writing and documentary
and also a lot of law in my work um
which is it's all been a helpful
platform to try new areas
great and yummy if you want to
continuous continue on
sure hi everyone my name is emig ma and
i graduated in class of 2018. um i'm i'm
chinese canadian and uh after undergrad
i spent two years at mckinsey out of the
new york office in corporate finance and
then moved to london where i spent two
years investing in school chains and
for-profit education technology
companies out of south africa and parts
of southeast asia as well
so
at gsb the the year before gsb i
actually took a bit of time and that's
where um i started writing again it
rekindled kind of my love for something
that i never really thought was possible
being a first generation immigrant
and at gsb i looked at just broadening
my horizons and uh learning about you
know what crea what creative fields
might look like and so um specifically
industry-wise i looked into media and
summered at sony out of la and then
after graduation i joined the
bertelsmann leadership development
program every year um burleson which
owns penguin random house the world's
largest publisher
takes about two to three people who do
this leadership rotation program and so
i had the opportunity to work across
berlin in germany then moved to new york
as part of the main publishing
office and then i was the first one to
go into toronto and work out of the
canadian office so i had a great
experience there and really learned a
lot about this black box of publishing
that you know it's still a mystery to
most writers um and decided partly due
to covet to take take some time and
actually complete my first novel and so
that's something i'm in the process of
finalizing at the moment and it's really
a period of transition where i'm looking
to get back into the workforce but at
the same time um
finalize the draft and uh and and
prepare that for submission so it's
really been a one-man startup for the
last two years on on this front and uh
i'm excited to to uh to continue along
that journey but also move back onto the
into the business field as well and jack
over to you
sure so um my background before uh going
to school and from the midwest
originally
had done mckinsey and private equity
after undergrad so in that sense i was
kind of down the middle of the fairway
there were a couple of things made me a
little different
as i was applying one i had done
a stint in politic politics in chicago
so i worked for the mayor in chicago
and then my wife and i were playing
together and she had a way cooler and
more interesting background so we ended
up somehow both getting in which was
amazing and attended together
um and i think when i was at school i
was looking to sort of zoom out and
decide
from my three jobs what i liked and what
i didn't sort of decide what i wanted to
do long term
and work on moving from sort of entry
level roles in each position to more of
a leadership or manager role
and i happened to uh catch the
entrepreneurial bug
and you know which is common at stanford
and
started spending more and more time with
the classmate working on business ideas
in agriculture
and ended up founding and running a kind
of hybrid investor and operator in
sustainable farming we have
farms up and down california and arizona
so
excited to meet everybody today and
tell you how awesome our experience was
at stanford
and sam
hey everybody sam biker
um i was very much on the fence about
getting an mba i had worked for the
obama campaign in 2012 after two years
of consulting and it was the best thing
i ever did loved it thought i wanted to
work in the public sector for the rest
of my life and so went to um
went to stanford law school
thinking that i would do that and um
law school is very much uh it's great in
many ways but it's very much an on the
beaten track kind of place and i
realized pretty soon i didn't want to be
on that track
and so ended up applying to the gsb
which i you know had never thought i
would do
um
and did a joint degree and it ended up
that the business school was far and
away though sort of more impactful and
meaningful and empowering part of that
um
so i used it to i used to really explore
i didn't really know what i wanted to do
coming in
and i ended up um after two years and
thanks to a ton of help from classmates
and professors and staff ended up
starting a public interest law firm
um so you know like jack sort of on the
like
in some ways that is a common path like
got the entrepreneurship bug started a
you know for-profit venture-backed
startup but we're also we're a licensed
law firm or a b corp and almost all our
work is helping disabled people get
government benefits
um and we just hired our 20th employee
um and i could never have done it
without stanford so excited to to share
emily over to you
hi i'm emily eliason i'm an 06 grad of
the gsb and in prior to the gsb i worked
in the early days of digital marketing i
worked for a small research market
research firm as well and i thought i
would stay in the digital world i did my
internship at yahoo
but ended up taking a kind of a more
traditional path in brand marketing
working for clorox after graduation and
um and i loved the work but i worked
mostly on the toilet products and
wondered if i could apply my skills for
something that i had a little bit more
interest in and actually through a great
program
that the gsb offers called alumni
consulting
groups and was able to get introduced
into the wine industry and and i've been
doing that now for about the past 15
years so i'm currently the general
manager of a um
of a company called geodusty wine and i
have three different kind of very very
different components of my job i do
farming i do
i do y marketing and then um i also uh
do some philanthropy so um i uh oversee
about uh four ranches a thousand acres
where we mostly sell grapes um produce
and sell grapes i
have started a new wine brand called
geodesy and the sole purpose of the wine
brand is to fund a women's leadership
and development program for
young women who want to have careers in
agriculture so i run the foundation in
the program and so that's kind of the
philanthropy
part and certainly all those different
things together never ever would have
been able to do or construct or figure
out without all the the great
skills
and experience i got into the gsb
and then rounding out the piano rebecca
would you like to introduce yourself
everyone it's so fun to hear all these
uh different
really wonderful stories uh i'm rebecca
and i
am at gsb class of 2005
and i i grew up in the sierra foothills
on a campground
and i was a whitewater rafting guide and
went for the first time to the east
coast for college and then moved to new
york city after college as a choro
fellow and that's where i really i would
say
became an urbanist and
came to love the connection of people in
place in a in an urban environment not
just on the river
and worked in urban development there
for a few years and then came
back to california what i thought was my
permanent trip home to california
i
for the gsb
and had an amazing two years
which we'll talk more about during q a
and i spent my summer as at
the white house office of management and
budget i'd been working a lot with local
governments in new york city and at
charlotte
across the eastern seaboard really and i
wanted to see what community development
policy looked like at more of the 30 000
foot level
then decided that was
way too ivory tower for me and i needed
to get more into the numbers and and so
i went to goldman sachs for
seven years in public sector and
infrastructure banking uh in new york
and then came back to san francisco and
uh left there to work for mayor edly in
san francisco on public-private
partnerships and infrastructure
related financing initially uh in
san francisco
rapidly pivoted to what became the most
important issue when i was there which
was housing
called up a lot of gsb classmates to say
tell me everything you know about real
estate despite what it says here i
didn't my first job wasn't really in
real estate uh so uh
and that's where i um
founded and then spun off the housing
accelerator fund which is the nonprofit
um
lending investing fund that i run now
and we invest in affordable housing uh
preservation and production in the bay
area
great well a wonderful and eclectic
group of panelists here um so again to
our audience members um feel free to go
to that q a box and type in any
questions that you would like to ask our
panelists i'll get us started though
with a handful of questions
and let's see the first question i'll
pose to rebecca and
yaming
why an mba and why specifically stanford
rebecca would you like to start
sure um
so
i would say um
why an mba
i
i went to undergraduate at brown uh
which i think i share that with another
panelist yeah and
you have
full freedom which is kind of scary at
brown there's no
set majors there's no core correct or
there's there's no core curriculum and i
didn't take
an econ math investing like none of it
none of none of those things i was fully
focused on
public health developing the burden of
disease in developing countries uh and
in my first job working in urban
development and and public private
partnerships things like brooklyn bridge
park and the high line in new york city
realized pretty quickly that in order to
get things done that i really cared
about at the local level having more of
that finance uh real estate uh
negotiations uh
business
um
skill set was really important and uh
but i
knew that the way i love to learn is
very relationship focused and it's a lot
about the people and i really care a lot
about leadership
and community and so that
those two things seemed like that that
led me to an mba
i knew that i wanted to be in california
place is really important to me stanford
i knew i wanted to be in the bay area
and so that was a big driver behind uh
stanford i wanted to be in the place
where i wanted to put in roots uh and
i also really loved the public
management program at stanford because
that intersection between the public and
private sectors has been a big focus for
me
yumming how about you
yeah i'll start off with my undergrad as
well um i went to school in canada which
is relatively uncommon um but i'm a
canadian and my school program was
actually based a lot on the harvard case
study method so my university at the
richard ivy school of business was
actually
is actually the second largest producer
of case studies in in the world behind
harvard so what
it's exactly the opposite of brown in
many ways right when rebecca was saying
we didn't have that much flexibility all
our class photographers cases and i want
and we didn't have that much choice
because it started really in the third
year and i knew i wanted to go back to
school again and broaden my horizons and
out of all the the programs it was clear
to me that stanford was the best for me
um
and then and i'll get it get into that a
little bit later but for and but the big
thing for me at the time was that it was
the right time i had spent two years in
new york out of mckinsey so i had gotten
you know that experience um already and
uh i was honestly a little bit burnt out
i was uh i've been leading these impact
investments and i think i went to travel
across 30 countries in two in two years
or something ridiculous like that i was
flying all over um spending a lot of
time in parts of africa looking at deals
and uh i knew that okay this is this
feels like the right time to go back to
school recharge and learn a lot of
different things and consider if i do
want to pivot
um
and uh
um specifically i was in london at the
time and i want to make that transition
back to north america where my family
family is
tactically my gmats i had scored well
but they were about to expire four years
have passed and so this was the year
and uh and when i looked at school
stanford was just clearly the one that i
was interested in i had worked with
founders for a year for a couple of
years i had that entrepreneurial um
itch and still really want to build
something um and at the time because i
was investing in education there was a
dual education mba program that i was
considering
i knew that there was a lot of
flexibility there were opportunities to
take classes across the street and
culture wise with this focus on
empathy and
being able to work on the soft skills in
addition to hard skills it was a bit of
a no-brainer
um so out of all the schools i applied
to by far stanford was the one that you
know i was excited to join
if anyone else has thoughts please feel
free to chime in at any point too
uh well i'll go to the uh the next
question here um and maybe jackie you
can start us off uh and uh rebecca if
you have comments um or emily as well
feel free to chime in uh but were there
any academic courses at stanford that
kind of forced you to stretch yourself
in new ways or maybe help enable your
success today jack you want to get us
started
yeah definitely one of the most helpful
courses for me was a winning writing
course stanford has a lecturer
who uh spent
he's for 35 years he's been an editor
with the new york times and he's helped
between 10 and 12 different pulitzer
prize-winning articles and we have him
as not just a
teacher of our writing class but as an
incredible mentor and friend he really
gets to know the students and so
i took his class and he sent an op-ed
that i wrote to the new york times which
ended up being published a week or two
after i graduated
um
he
and that was about discrimination and
toward women's sexual wellness
businesses he also brought nick kristof
to our class and set up a call between
me and like one of the most famous
journalists um which was incredible
um and he's he really the faculty really
want to help you succeed so he's right
now helping as a recommender on a
fellowship so i love that course i also
really like to be a professor named
laura ariaga andreessen who created a
women in leadership course and has a
long time philanthropy course but
outside of her class she would have
dinners at her house with arianna
huffington and darren walker and i think
i spent every week at her house at some
point um because she was such an
incredible
mentor that the other two quickly i'll
mention is i really liked the there were
two classes about impact investing that
i took and then we also had a class
about how to negotiate term sheets as an
angel investor or venture capitalist
which i think for classmates that were
going to go work at a vc firm might have
been less relevant but for those that
wanted to do more entrepreneurial
investing the term sheet classes
mattered in particular and the faculty
would normally charge thousands of
dollars an hour as a consultant but you
got to have his office hours for free as
a student
or included intuition
rebecca over to you were there any
academic experiences that stand out
yeah and
so i was in the inaugural class of it
for a class that's that's still going in
his ground called designing for extreme
affordability
and
that was basically we were partnered
with a specific community-based
organization in this case it was uh
in southern india and focused on in over
the course of the semester working with
engineering students and
and
other students across depending on kind
of who came in law students
across the
campus
on coming up with a business plan um for
and prototyping uh
a water system in this case for farmers
for less than a dollar a day
and that was like my first
start of it like that that i still think
about that and launching the housing
accelerator fund just that and it was it
was before design thinking was like so
much the thing and rapid iterations and
fail fast it was like very
early edge which i think you often get
which is so awesome at the gsb like the
earliest edge thinking and approach to
how do we
how do we think and create things and
work together across different sectors
in different ways and so i loved that
class and it will definitely echo what
jackie said about the access overall to
the professors and uh the faculty
dinners there's i have a professor who
beloved professor jim van horn who
taught corporate finance for decades
which is another favorite class of mine
i still think about it every board that
i sit on when i actually understand how
the inc how the income statement of the
cash flow statement and the balance
sheet all fit together i thank jim van
horn for that and especially my running
my own organization now and
having we still send each other
cards every holiday season and you know
like what like he writes a lot in them
uh so i think those kinds of connections
that you can build with the professor's
word
is really a highlight also
emily how about you anything that stood
out from an academic class or experience
all of those i had some commonalities
with what jackie and rebecca had said
and completely agree you know the only
um one that i would add that i found
incredibly impactful was touchy-feely
and so um at the gsb we have a course
that is nicknamed touchy feely it's
called interpersonal dynamics and
in large part it's kind of group therapy
with a bunch of mba students which is
kind of scary and um and it tends to be
one of the most impactful classes that
folks have i think you know for me
stanford was
so um it was great to have uh so many
classes where there were nuts and bolts
learning right learning um finance
similar to rebecca i have a liberal arts
background so that was really important
for me to get um to get some of that
experience understanding logistics
understanding modeling and marketing um
but you know ultimately i think stanford
does such a good job developing leaders
and that's really what that class is
about it's kind of hard to describe um
but it is one that i think a lot of
people get something out of it's very
unique to stanford and um and that was
one that i i got a lot out of and
honestly every day every week there's
something that comes up that i learned
in touchy feely
great
all right this next question i'll pose
to um jack and then send over to uh
were there any stanford clubs or
extracurricular activities that you
participated in that maybe helped you
explore or
think about new career paths or
interests that you had jack maybe
starting with you
yeah um i came in with kind of a big
company background consulting and
private equity firm and uh even in
politics i work for
a large organization and um
i was really interested in exploring
doing something again in politics so i
spent some time in the
government politics group and like for
example we went like knocked on doors in
nevada which was really uh cool
i also spent some time in
the entrepreneurship
type clubs and food and ag where i ended
up working
um and i think that sort of morphed over
time
into
a more and more just like the informal
extracurricular that's very common of
working on
whether it's some kind of side project
that's professional in nature or
starting a company or things like that
that many
of my classmates were were doing
simultaneous with school and i think the
club sort of provided the
foundation for that where you're meeting
other people that have shared interests
and then
my experience was over the two years it
became more and more real and more and
more
uh time intensive and kind of led into
what i'm doing now so the clubs were
super helpful for me
to just explore
spaces that i didn't know as well or
find people with shared interests and
then the other extracurricular thing i
was going to mention is
maybe this is outside of the scope of
this question but we did a few gsts and
other travel
that were just
massively important for us to
feel like a closer connection with some
of our classmates
i think we
kind of
uh sort of met everyone quickly and it's
400 people on you know right when you
get there and can be a little
overwhelming but then traveling for a
couple weeks with a smaller group of 10
or 20
um really forged some some bonds that my
wife and i still talk to the people that
we went to
some of these trips with so
i don't know that that's quite in the
scope of extracurriculars but it was
really important to our experience
yeah those global study trips i think
are highlights for for many students um
yielding over to you
yeah so i was involved in our arts media
and entertainment club i ended up
organizing and leading the future of
media conference that we have every year
my first year and moderating some panels
on it so scooter braun came during our
year who's the main agent for justin
bieber and uh honestly i learned way
more about how
he kind of fell out of favor and then
came back through the roast than i ever
thought i would um
but in addition to clubs i ended up
attending a ton of talks throughout
campus so not just at the gsb
but uh often in other other fields so in
particular whenever authors came like
george saunders anthony doyer i had the
chance to listen to these people who
aren't who never came to canada in
particular and uh got to meet some of
them as well and some of those
conversations i had in advice i got made
me more confident ultimately you know
invest
in myself and invest in in this dream
that i always had um and then one other
thing that i'd add in terms of
extracurriculars it was related to a
course i took in anthropology and
psychiatry as part of stanford um but i
ended up doing spending eight weeks
working with formerly homeless adults in
san mateo on improv therapy and so every
week we carpool over and work with these
adults who are in various um
shapes
within in terms of their mental health
and it was a really really impactful
experience for me and i was able to
apply a lot of what i learned not just
in that class but from gsb to trying to
connect with um these people and
something i always bring with me
thank you
this next question um sam i'll have you
kick it off and then maybe we'll go over
to jackie next um but starting with you
sam
how did you find uh career support at
the stanford gsb did you leverage the
career management center or any of our
other centers like our center for
entrepreneurial studies or center for
social innovation or other parts of the
campus how did you kind of go about that
career support process yeah i'll give a
big pitch for this um one thing i didn't
expect the gsb is at least you can
correct me if i'm wrong here but the
gsb's staff to student ratio is crazy
um it felt one to one it was probably
three or four to one but it was you know
there were there are
so many fantastic people whose job is to
provide student support and so
um those three centers lisa listed i
think i used all of them you know
entrepreneurial studies coordinates a
bunch of really great classes
um
and does a bunch of research on certain
startups that i you know as a lawyer
like read in great detail before
starting a company um
the cmc is amazing like i think um i
remember law school had you know like
there was the
law firm people who told you how to get
a law firm job and there was the like
public interest people who told you how
to get like one of three types of public
interest jobs gsb had you know 17
different specialties you could select
from
um
grace yokoi on their team i remember i
spent way too much time with her just
being like can i start a startup this
seems insane like and she really helped
give me the confidence to do that and it
was such a
the general vibe was just such a choose
your own adventure and like they were so
great the staff have such a reservoir of
knowledge about who good alumni are to
talk to
um what good classes are to take it
really meant a lot to me
jackie how about over to you
yeah that's amazing i also used all of
the centers you mentioned the center for
social innovation was fantastic they had
a fellowship between your first and
second years that a lot of students did
um or a number of students did that were
creating social
entrepreneurial ventures um and then i
coupled that with a fellowship uh an
internship where you could work for an
impact organization and i worked in
impact investing and there was tons of
funding for both of those i still talk
to the staff um pretty regularly from
center for social innovation on
mentorship and they're so helpful
um i also found that the peer support
incredibly helpful for a career
especially because um like lisa
mentioned i think about a fifth of
classmates start their own venture and
so while you could absolutely go into
consulting or finance i didn't feel any
pressure to not do something
entrepreneurial because there were tons
of other students starting
new things and so it didn't feel as
crazy or scary since everyone else was
bootstrapping or fundraising
um and then a couple more um
the career uh center was really helpful
especially in my first year i was
interested in venture capital and
investing and i had no investing
experience and it comes from the
nonprofit world and
the
uh staff was so helpful at
understanding the world of investing and
how to
couch your experience in ways where you
get opportunities a professor rob siegel
let me work with his venture capital
fund to get exposure during school
um
there was also an accelerator called
starducks where you could get financial
aid and accelerator wrap around support
and then the last thing i'll mention is
that for people that go into the
nonprofit sector or the public sector um
there's loan forgiveness which is really
helpful so i receive probably like nine
thousand dollars a year now to repay my
loans which is super helpful and it's
not taxed um and that's also really
helpful for pursuing a career in social
entrepreneurship
great thank you uh this next question
jack i'll maybe have you kick us off and
then um over to rebecca next and anyone
else who wants to chime in because i
know this was a popular one but how have
you leveraged your classmates alumni
faculty or the stanford network more
broadly um either professionally
speaking or even just personally
speaking jack you want to start us off
yeah i mean i think there's no way my
like sam brought up how powerful that
usb was and starting his business
totally
feel the same way
from
meeting people in my industry to
advice on how to set up my company to
i've hired a couple uh gs beers the
years behind me
um
i think maybe like one very like
tangible thing is on fundraising so
i'd say
somewhere between like 20 and 50 million
of fundraising has been from stanford uh
either classmates referrals from
classmates um and uh
other alumni
um so like it's been massively impactful
to me
um
across the board from advice to hiring
to fundraising to
um all sorts of ways so there's just no
way my business and my career would be
where it was if i hadn't started
the business while i was at the gsp
rebecca i echo all of those things and i
think the um
i mean i would say in general one of the
things that maybe attracts people to
stanford and the gsb but then is is
really
um
the seeds are watered when you're there
is a
a level of comfort and openness to
reaching out to your classmates
with questions
for help at the moment when you need it
to celebrate their successes
that
at a level that i don't see in many
other communities especially of that
size
so i think that that there's just a
base level of of care and a sense of
community
and that's created and further
cultivated within
the class that is
that really
stays with you so that it's like you
know i would say any specific
situation personal professional you know
the like
my top five like phone numbers that i
would call different situation is
probably going to be somebody who i know
from the gsb
uh
and i mean i you know i have a
few great friends who were now parents
at the same school
we go for
um weekly runs together with some of
them i met my husband at the gsb so
that's pretty transformational uh
and and i think then specifically
particularly for me at career transition
points i i really that's when i kind of
reached out beyond like the closest
concentric circle
and tapped into kind of a broader
network i have a
gsb
um
alum from many years from before my
class who's on my board right now so
those sorts of those kind of moments i
think there's such a deep great network
and people
have always been really
happy
to help
you can also chime in if there's time um
and i love everything you share rebecca
i was gonna add there's a program
that student organized at the gsb called
talk where students give about a
40-minute talk about anything in their
lives and
i found that incredibly helpful because
people know what you care about
and can support you the rest of your
time when i was at the gsb i knew i
wanted to work in women's sexual
wellness and sex tech which was
absolutely terrifying for me because
it's
it was a very stigmatized area and i
didn't know anyone else with an mba that
was going into that path although now
this year like six harvard and stanford
mbas have reached out to me that are
working in women's sex tech which is so
exciting two years later but um
i felt that it was a great practice
ground to be talking about topics that
terrified me both in class and in talk
and socially and really prepared me to
get
the confidence to then write and your
time's not bad about those subjects and
now i have no problem talking about them
whether it's in a sex discrimination
lawsuit or
a meeting with pretty much anyone but it
it without those two years in a safe
space i don't think i don't know how i
would have done that and then as an alum
you have so many whatsapp groups where
we have a women's founder group that
meets monthly we have entrepreneur
groups we have bay area groups and so
you can always send a question like are
you a documentary lawyer or i'm
researching competitors in this market
and everyone will know all the ceos in
some startup space um we just had a
classmate of mine that
a year out of school successfully led a
camp a shareholder activist approach to
get three
sustainability experts on the board of
exxon mobil um to move exxon mobil to
more sustainable directions and we had a
whole webinar where he talked to all of
our classmates off the record about
their strategies and learning so we're
still very much in contact personally
and professionally and i also found as a
woman at the gsb pursuing
those areas i shared about men were so
helpful classmates connected me with
like book publishers because they
thought that you should write a book
about these subjects and
really
men as well as women were just
incredibly personally supportive in a
way that meant a lot to me
well let's go to some of the questions
from our audience here because we've had
a few
submitted now so uh here's a question
from michaels he says wow incredible to
hear all these different experiences how
do you kind of resist getting caught up
in the more traditional recruiting
tracks in business school
since it can be difficult to balance
your passions with kind of practicality
and finances so anyone want to tackle
that one
i could i could take one step i mean i
um
i think
my wife and i were both going to school
and so we were both paying
a lot of tuition and um
i definitely felt that that pressure to
go
um in my case what i was concerned was
going back to the firm where i was at
and we ended up taking out some loans
and stuff to figure out how to do it
but i will say stanford was super
helpful
there's lots of programs that folks have
mentioned about if you're going into
non-profit there's um you know extra uh
incentives sort of to do that
and um lots of fellowships and other
things that i know my classmates took
advantage of and i just felt um
financially there was a lot of resources
there to help figure that out and then
the culture of my class was
so um
you know supportive that
just in terms of like the fomo of what
you're gonna do with your career i just
can't imagine a better
place to do something off the beaten
path because so many people were sort of
joining you in that and um that alone
helped everyone like really do what they
were passionate about and not
feel sort of pressured to
do what everyone else was doing
basically
i don't know
yeah
i'd echo what jack said and just add
briefly there were a bunch of classes
and all my favorite ones that jsp fit
this description
that would have one alum per class
period come in and sort of be a guest
speaker each one really cares about them
sometimes they just talk
and that was really what gave me
confidence because it feels a lot less
crazy once you've met 12 people who are
like yeah i was in your shoes
you know
two five ten years ago and this was
scary and now i get it here's where i am
and that was just that was so i would
never
have gone off the beaten track without
that
yeah i also had great advice from the
classmate the first year of gsb
uh i was deciding whether to uh do
interviews for consulting or not and but
i knew that i had these other passions
and she had the idea give it six months
or eight months where you just let
yourself fully focus on your
entrepreneurial
area and then assess in six months so
you can always apply for consulting in
your second year of mba but set goals
for yourself and then see where you're
at at that point and six months in i was
so in love with my work and the goals
had all shifted and they'd all changed
but you knew there was no going back um
so that peer support was incredibly
helpful and on the finances like you
mentioned the loan forgiveness did help
there were different fellowships that
you could apply for they were obviously
competitive but a couple of my
classmates got i think 110 000 to create
a non-profit and there was a few others
there's a few others like that um
plus the network that you're getting is
incredibly helpful like others have
mentioned for their fundraising so
there's ways to um bolster the
financial opportunities and i think
that um it just
definitely was a helpful financial
investment
here's another question it says looking
back what's one thing you would do
differently during your time at the gsd
he wants to take that one
i can try
i think looking back you know it was
something that um was really pounded
into us at the gsb so it wasn't as if
the opportunities weren't there but
honestly just take more risks it is such
a risk-free environment in that way and
it is the opportunity to
really have all of these incredible
people around you professors and
alums and classmates
and you really have the opportunity to
ask all the dumb questions that you want
to ask and um and you know just pick
people's brains and i think having um
you know saying that you're a student at
the gsb is a huge door opener for
talking to all sorts of people and um
and at the time i think you know it it
seems a little risky um but really
compared to what things are like you
know in the real world outside of the
gsb bubble um it's really a great great
opportunity to take advantage of um of
having those two years to just
experiment and play around and um and
just talk to a bunch of different people
to sort of figure out where it is that
you want to go
you know not just in the one or two
years after school but you know in the
next five 10 15 years because i think um
and i know some of the questions um that
have come through have asked about
pivoting and i think you know all of us
probably had very clear goals and ideas
of what we were going to do with the
rest of our lives when we applied
and then a lot of times that changed it
changed for me while i was at the gsb
and then it changed again five years
after and it changed again five years
after that
and so it's good to kind of have all of
those skills and experience from the gsp
that you can draw on
anything else that you would do
differently anyone
at the gsb knowing what you know now
i didn't do a global study trip i regret
that
that's already been mentioned
all right uh well maybe we'll pivot off
of what emily just was talking about
with career pivots so we do have some um
questions here about
um all of you mentioned that in one way
or another the stanford gsb has offered
an opportunity to pivot from your old
career path into a new one looking back
now did you know exactly what you wanted
to end up in post mba kind of in your
current role now um and how you would
leverage your gsb degree to get there or
was this sort of an unplanned
serendipitous process that led you to
where you are so does anyone want to
talk about their path or the pivot
you want to go ahead jackie no i can go
after you
okay so i i wouldn't say necessarily
when i went to gsb i made this pivot
that i wanted i wanted to become a
writer right and to be clear
after this last year i definitely don't
want to be a full-time writer but what i
will say is that during gsb it made me
more confident to take risks my career
and a lot of that has
has to do with what jack and sam said
earlier the culture where you saw people
taking these risks where people felt
comfortable talking about failures and
failing at startups and coming back
and so that's something where
you know that made me decide to leave
publishing for a period of time feeling
comfortable that i knew that world well
enough that if i had something that was
worthy of being published even if maybe
there's a one percent chance of that
happening more or less that was
comfortable taking those odds on um with
you know what i what i believe that i
had and being comfortable that i can
recover if things don't work out
um and so i i think like that makes me
more comfortable even now as i'm
transitioning right you could argue do i
even know what i want to do 20 years
from now i i would honestly say that i
wouldn't be able to predict that at the
moment but i am comfortable that no
matter what happens
based on my track record based on my gsb
experience that i'll be able to bounce
back from it um and i think that's one
of the biggest things that gsb taught me
about pivots is yes there are all the
tactical things that you can do there
are the steps that you can take like i
i want a short story competition run by
the guardian and by harper collins
before i decide to take time off right i
actually got into my top tier mfa
program and i'm about halfway done it's
a remote one so i can do it during work
but i did i built support networks
around me and so there are tactical ways
in which gsb help me think about these
things so i do things systematically but
i think the biggest thing is the courage
to be able to do pivots because you see
other people doing it it becomes a
little less daunting and helps you build
that confidence
yeah
i that's so beautiful and i for me
i
it was
there was a lot of serendipity that led
to finding new passions in grad school
when i applied i probably thought i
wanted to work for a foundation and
international development and now what
i'm doing is completely different
because i had a several personal
experience in grad school that made me
really passionate about ending sexual
assault and creating a
more equal culture i started business
school
and a month into it the metoo movement
kicked off so all of those things
impacted my career very much
um
and then
there was a we were thinking about a
question earlier about like how to
prepare for a career
in a non-traditional path but i think
it's really about finding your passions
and then when people see you doing what
you're passionate about others notice
your excitement and possibility and get
on board i also feel that right now i'm
so i'm two years out of gsb but i'm
preparing for another career pivot where
i've been a social entrepreneur and
founded a couple of non-profits but i
realized recently that i'm really
passionate about writing and that
there's a few books that i want to write
some are about
law and i don't have a law degree
um and
in my professor that i mentioned earlier
from the writing class is really
supportive of me going into
investigative journalism and i didn't
know any of that i didn't really know
any professional writers so it's cool
hearing your story too you mean um but
i've been just putting in place the
foundations to apply to different
fellowships or to try to structure my
finances to figure out how to do writing
and while i didn't do a lot a ton of
writing other than that class during the
gsb i definitely echo that you develop
this sense that anything is possible you
develop a sense that you can learn new
skills um and that you can dive into
um
a new area because every day at the gsb
it feels like
you you can just
create whatever you want to create
because you're seeing people that are
doing that every day
maybe pivoting off of something that
jackie said and i think you mean you
also talked about it maybe having some
interest in the ed school and let's see
we've got sam who did the law degree the
joint degree how did any of you
leverage other parts of stanford
university either taking classes there
or connecting with students or programs
or talks you know talk a little bit more
broadly about your stanford wide
experience
yeah i'll just briefly share this sort
of joint degree perspective i think
there were
felt like maybe a quarter or a fifth of
my class were joint degrees and with a
ton of different stuff so it's pretty
easy once you get to stanford to apply
to do a joint degree in almost any other
school
they all combine neatly with the
business school so you get to take some
cross classes there's a community people
who are doing that so there was the
the you know doc the md mbas many of
them were doctors now the jd mbas the
there were phd mbas which seems insane
to me um
but there was a huge mix and
um
the school stanford i think much more
than most universities really is
integrated there in a way that the
departments work together to coordinate
stuff and made the scheduling easy
and so for anyone who's considering that
just know it was a
it was made really easy to do it and a
lot of folks get to school and then add
that
maybe one last super quick question in
our last minute or so
what is an experience that you could
have only had at stanford
i definitely think talk the experience
of hearing hundreds of classmates share
about the most vulnerable experiences of
their lives and be so supportive for me
was transformational it there's such a
culture of vulnerability at the gsb and
of true
support and and i just thought okay my
classmates will support all my other
classmates topics but i really honestly
went into my talk thinking everyone's
gonna hate me after i give a talk about
female sexuality for for 40 minutes and
actually it was the opposite everyone
was so supportive and i felt like i
belonged at the gsb because it really
created a feeling of being accepted
do you want to recognize that we are
getting to uh pardon me the end of our
session here
and i want to thank all of our panelists
for sharing your perspectives today in
your various fields i think there's just
tremendous diversity represented in your
backgrounds and your experiences and
again it just highlights how wonderfully
flexible this mba degree and educational
experience is
i also want to thank all of our
attendees today for your interest in
stanford we hope that this is just the
start of your stanford gsb journey and
we definitely invite you to continue it
one great thing you can do is go to
mystanford.mba
if you haven't been there already you
can create a personalized dashboard by
taking a really quick quiz and that will
help you
learn a little bit more about students
or alumni who might have similar
interests as you do
events that are coming up if you start
an application it'll track your
application progress along the way
so just lots of wonderful opportunities
to continue to learn more about stanford
at mystanford.mba
again thank you to everyone for
attending today and best of luck in your
journey for an off the beaten path
career thank you
[Music]